precisamos aprender a requerer nos
enquanto subimos essa frase de angela
davis e níger uma série de inquietações
pra pensar o empoderamento das mulheres
o empoderamento que está tão em voga na
sociedade embora não seja novidade
ela está na ordem do dia hoje pra pensar
o protagonismo das mulheres
e aí pensando na minha trajetória
eu refleti quando as mulheres me
ergueram pra que eu pudesse subir e e
fiquei também refletindo sobre como
complexificar o protagonismo dessas
mulheres sem pensar na estrutura racial
do brasil ou seja como não pensar quais
os lugares em que as mulheres negras
ocupam na estrutura social pensando no
nosso legado escravocrata é de quase 400
anos é possível não vê cor é possível a
gente pensar as mulheres como um sujeito
universal sem debater estruturalmente o
contexto histórico racial do brasil
sobre essa perspectiva eu fiquei então
analisando como a gente desenvolve
organicamente um daltonismo orgânico é
elaborado através dessa estrutura racial
o daltonismo que é na verdade a perda é
de uma perspectiva visual que fica
incapaz de distinguir as cores na
realidade estou utilizando esse termo é
não anunciem tido meramente retórico
porque de fato nós somos capazes de
identificar as cores identificar é os
estratos sociais em que os corpos
brancos ou não brancos estão ocupando na
sociedade
mas esse discurso de não ver co ele
escamoteia uma série de índices bem
problemáticos 70% da população pobre do
brasil é negra
sessenta por cento das mulheres que
morrem nos partos são mulheres negras 62
por cento das mulheres vítimas de
violência obstetrícia são mulheres
negras
elas são menos tocadas e - anestesiados
nos processos obstetrícios além disso as
mulheres negras ingressam no mercado de
trabalho aos nove anos no mercado e se
geralmente relacionado ao mercado é de
emprego doméstico e geralmente não
registrado em carteira e suscetível a
uma série de violências né como a falta
de fiscalização e regulamentação que os
espaços domésticos proporcionam o
trabalho doméstico nos quais as mulheres
negras estão inseridas
me chama especialmente a atenção uma vez
que eu sou filha de empregada doméstica
sou neta de empregada doméstica e sua
irmã até um certo o tempo da minha vida
fui irmã de empregada doméstica e mãe é
essa que tem uma diferença de 1 ano de
idade apenas entre mim e ela
e esses espaços domésticos fizeram com
que eu vivesse essa realidade
passivamente por um longo tempo
foi também o serviço doméstico que
financiou grande parte da minha vida mas
pensar esses espaços domésticos geravam
em minha inquietação e uma indignação
com esse legado da escravidão porque
também no período da escravidão da
escravidão nos ocupávamos espaço e eu
pretendia é a via em mim uma necessidade
de romper com esse legado da minha
família mas é só foi possível porque
essas mulheres estiveram me rendo pra
que eu pudesse subir
ingressei no mercado financeiro me
formei em administração é migrado e tome
graduando em ciências econômicas em um
dado momento da minha vida eu resolvi
pesquisar o protagonismo das mulheres
negras através da antropologia social
essa modificação que pode parecer à
primeira vista bem contraditória na
verdade ela tem uma sequência muito
lógica
as primeiras informações da minha vida
elas tinham a intenção de amy subsidiá é
e manter a minha sobrevivência né
a minha subsistência mínima a partir do
momento que eu entendi que eu já
conseguia é me desvencilhar desse
vínculo empregatício e pleitear outros
caminhos
eu enveredei para a pesquisa de mulheres
negras
paralelo a esse caminho profissional a
minha militância também me deu todos os
subterfúgios necessários para que eu me
questionar se o tempo inteiro porque
quando a gente de baixo protagonismo das
mulheres não complexificam anos também a
cor dessas mulheres porque a gente não
pensa é que esses atravessamentos classe
raça gênero quando convertidos
eles geram uma matriz de opressão
ainda que precisa ser debatida com
honestidade e era sobre esse daltonismo
orgânico que eu estava preocupada em
olhar com mais atenção e me de ter um
pouco mais os coletivos negros e me
deram todo o aparato teórico e de
militância para que eu pudesse pensar de
fato as contribuições da população negra
os seus saberes apps tecnologias e o seu
protagonismo efetivo quebrando algumas
verdades é questionáveis né
estabelecidas pelo senso comum pelo mito
da democracia racial e tantos outros
mas os espaços é das mulheres
os espaços seguros que nós criamos para
debater com honestidade e com franqueza
foi o que me deu toda uma força pra
avançar na me colocar como intelectual
negra um caminho que eu não acreditava
ser possível
foi no bloco de percussão de mulheres
formados apenas por mulheres percussão
que o universo é hegemonicamente
masculino que a gente começa a elaborar
outras formas de contestar o o sistema
de opressão né
dentro daquele espaço físico em que as
mulheres são ao mesmo tempo
protagonistas mas que estão preocupadas
com outras mulheres é de dar
visibilidade complexificar suas
realidades e protagonismos foi que eu
entendi a potência de estarmos juntas eu
compreendi o que é enquanto subimos foi
dentro do bloco coruja e formado em 2015
por dez mulheres de diversas classes
sociais de diversos cantos do país é de
cores diferentes mulheres negras e não
negras juntas que a gente começou então
a elaborar uma outra forma de ser e
estar
mundo uma forma colaborativa e uma forma
tão potente que me faz hoje ter a
certeza de que é necessário realmente
erguer-nos enquanto subimos nos
importarmos honestamente com umas asas
umas com as outras
sem deixar de complexifica os
atravessamentos dessas relações
então aqui fica na verdade uma forma de
analisar como a forma de pensar as
mulheres negras não pode ser uma
prerrogativa exclusiva da população
negra pensar que não existe um sistema é
que de opressão independente do nosso
prato grande protagonismo também a gente
sempre terceiriza as responsabilidades
como se o sistema fosse uma entidade é
que em independence da o nosso
posicionamento mas na verdade nós
operamos esse sistema
quantos livros nós lemos ao longo de
nossas vidas desses livros quanto são
escritos por mulheres desses livros
contas quantos foram escritos por
mulheres negras
quantas vezes você se consultaram com
médicos ou advogados negros
quantas vezes viram negros e negras e
outras posições que não fossem os
espaços de serviços domésticos ou
subempregos com o perdão do eufemismo né
então entender que também somos
responsáveis por essas e arquias sociais
essas estratificações raciais pra mim
faz todo o sentido quando percebo dentro
dos espaços em que o ato quer seja
corrigida a ideia que seja dentro da
academia ou da minha própria família que
a força coletiva e o grito organizado
tem uma potência avassaladora para
derrubar todas essas mazelas
hierarquizações que a gente consiga
acabar construindo e quando nos
silenciamos ou quando nos utilizamos
desse daltonismo orgânico também
acabamos por reforçar
reforçamos as estruturas de poder
quando a gente utiliza argumentos do
tipo eu não vejo cor ou o amor não tem
como
negando 358 anos centralização dos
corpos negros e negando que a sua
integração à na transição do serviço
escravocratas para o serviço salarial
dado se deu de uma forma tão tranquila
só que não essas complexifica ações elas
precisam estar em nosso dia a dia e nem
sempre os responsáveis são os meramente
um sistema com a mão invisível do
racismo
quando a gente começa a olhar com
cuidado a nossa rede de relações
as pessoas que nos cercam ou se
comprometer efetivamente com a ruptura
dos estados coco com a inserção de uma
diversidade efetiva nos espaços em que a
gente ocupa e isso é empoderamento na
administração a gente estudou em
parlamentos né que significa você não só
dá as ferramentas necessárias para uma
pessoa subordinada à mente a você né não
só das ferramentas mais a todas as
condições
é pra que ela tem autonomia para a
tomada de decisão nesse sentido também
eu fico pensando empoderamento eu não
posso analisar o protagonismo feminino
mi descolando dessa estrutura e
terceirizando a responsabilidade pelas
pressões
está tudo muito conectado e o pouco que
eu faço o que eu consigo
é aí que enquanto eu subo faz toda uma
diferença
e mais uma vez eu gostaria de finalizar
com angela davis na intelectual negra
filósofo estadunidense mas que tem como
reflexo desse processo de racionalização
das apps tecnologias começa a ser
traduzida para o português no brasil
apenas em 2010 sendo que ela produz é
uma bibliografia muito importante para o
movimento negro para as mulheres negras
desde a década de 70 e 80
então eu convido para que todos e todas
superam esse daltonismo orgânico
meramente retórico que mantém as
estruturas de poder e finalizo com
geladeiras falando que não não basta não
ser racista
a gente precisa ter atitudes anti
racistas
obrigada
[Aplausos]